tiens alexandre bonjour alors vous avez
écrit sur ce sujet récemment est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'est
que cette nouvelle monnaie un bonjour
magali olivier alors le bitcoin est une
crypto monnaie c'est à dire une monnaie
virtuelle écrite est entièrement créé
par informatique qui n'est ni garantie
ni régulés par une banque centrale comme
le relais par la bce par exemple les
mille tonnes est devenu le
porte-étendard de ses cryptes aux
monnaies mais des milliers d'autres ont
été créés tels que les terium ou le
dodge colt quelles raisons peuvent
expliquer justement le récent succès du
bitcoin est bien ce décollage et
spectaculaire est notamment dû au fait
que les investisseurs ne voient plus
seulement les bitcoins comme un objet de
spéculation mais aussi comme une
véritable monnaie et comme
l'investissement de long terme
bitcoin a ainsi réussi à s'attirer la
confiance de grands fonds spéculatifs de
wall street comme jpmorgan blackrock qui
ont acheté plusieurs millions de dollars
de bitcoin du point de vue des petits
investisseurs limitent collier s'ancre
de plus en plus sur le réel avec un
nombre croissant d'entreprises qui
acceptent d'être payé en mille tonnes on
peut citer l'exemple du constructeur de
véhicules électriques tesla qui a
annoncé le 8 février qu'elle envisageait
d'accepter le paiement au beacon ce qui
a fait prendre 13% à la crypto monnaies
bon cette annonce n'était pas très
surprenant car le célèbre patron de
tesla elon musk est un fervent défenseur
des crypto monnaie et ses tweets sur le
bitcoin ou le dodge cogne sont
régulièrement tuer leurs cours or pour
faire un petit retour pierre alexandre
le bitcoin il existe depuis plusieurs
années mais son évolution n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille et finalement non
en effet le premier bloc de la block
chaining cogne été créée en 2009
il a fallu attendre deux ans pour
qu'elle me cogne vaille un dollar et
ensuite progresser régulièrement jusqu'à
atteindre pas de 20 mille dollars fin
mai mais 17 puis s'est effondré début
il a alors continué à fluctuer jusqu'à
un nouvel effondrement à moins de 5000 $
le 16 mars dernier
c'est à partir de ce moment là que
commence la folle envolée du bitcoin
qu'il a fait grimper jusqu'à plus de 57
milles dollars le 20 février pour donner
un ordre de grandeur
les 18 6 millions de bitcoin circulation
valait alors au total plus de mille
milliards de dollars
pierre alex en a parlé du succès
précédemment du bitcoin est expert
considère-t-il ce récent succès comme
solides ou peut-il s'agir d'une dune
finalement alors d'un côté comme on
vient de le voir le bitcoin gagnante la
débilité
il pourrait à terme concurrencer les
monnaies nationales mais de l'autre
de nombreux experts affirment que
l'euphorie qui entoure l egypte aux
monnaies connaîtra inévitablement une
correction importante grèce à savoir
quand elle certains estiment que la
baisse entamée il ya une semaine et que
le début de cette correction alors on se
pose la question effectivement ce que le
bitcoin est un investissement à risque
oui tout à fait ces hauts et ces bas met
en avant l'un des défauts majeurs du
bitcoin qui est sa grande volatilité
c'est une caractéristique qui permet des
gains rapides en cas de hausse mais
deiber tout aussi rapide qu'en cas de
baisse
il faut également savoir que les
bitcoins fera l'objet de piratage
informatique et servir à financer des
activités frauduleuses comme nous le
rappelle le ministère français de
l'économie
il est par conséquent très probable que
ces problèmes amène les pouvoirs publics
à tenter de réguler les limaces culte
aux monnaies dans un avenir assez proche
affaire à suivre donc oui merci beaucoup
pierre alexandre pour ces faits analyse
on va retrouver évidemment tous ces
précieux détails dans votre article sur
notre site internet
rt france poids tv